All right, stream is on.
Let's jump right in.
Welcome to Thursday.
We've a lot to cover today.
So, today we're going to briefly uh
recap
the uh fault tolerance or fault
classification stuff that we began to
discuss last time.
And I'm going to add to that a little
bit by talking about uh forms of fault
tolerance.
And then we're going to talk about
implementing reliable delivery.
So, we began to talk about reliable
delivery last time. This time we're
actually going to talk about how one
might implement it.
Then we're going to get to item potents.
A topic that came up uh I think on the
first day of class.
Uh now we're actually going to talk
about what it means.
And we're going to talk about
at least once,
at most once,
and exactly once
delivery.
And then I hope we make it to discussing
reliable broadcast.
And implementing reliable broad
broadcast.
So, there's a lot on the agenda today.
So, we'd better jump in.
Okay, so fault classification. Uh so,
last time, if you recall, uh we drew a
picture
about of um
ways to classify faults. And
and we ended up with something like
this. So, we talked about crash faults,
which are a subset of omission faults,
which are a subset of Byzantine faults.
And I've left some stuff out of here.
Like we talked about uh the category of
fail-stop faults, which are a subset of
crash faults. And then we talked about
timing faults, which aren't in here. But
these are the the categories that I want
to focus on the most.
So,
it should be pointed out that this
particular hierarchy of faults is not
the the whole story.
So, we could subdivide some of these
classes of faults further.
So, for instance, take Byzantine faults.
Some Byzantine faults are going to be
easier to deal with than others.
What might be an example of a Byzantine
fault that might be relatively easy to
deal with? Any ideas?
And you can either say it out loud or
type it into Zulip.
Or if you're on Twitch, that works, too.
Twitch chat works, too.
One that acts like a crash fault. Yeah,
okay. So,
yeah, what would be an example? So,
yeah, if a process is pretending to have
crashed, then
the way that you might deal with a crash
fault might be to
declare like if it seems as though a
machine has crashed,
maybe your response will be to just
declare that machine dead and bring up
another machine.
So, yeah, no response kind of falls into
that category, too.
So,
yeah, I mean a machine that's acting as
though it has crashed is
indistinguishable from one that's
crashed, right? So, in that case we can
kind of downgrade the fault from being a
Byzantine fault to a crash fault. What
else? What other examples of are are
cases where we can downgrade a fault to
kind of a easier to deal with class of
faults?
Well, let me suggest one thing.
So,
if you have a message that gets altered
or corrupted in some way, then that's a
Byzantine fault.
But some kinds of these alterations and
corruptions could be detectable.
So, there are techniques like checksums,
for example, or error-correcting codes
that you can use to tell that a message
has been corrupted.
And if you get a message and you can
tell that it's been corrupted, that's
much better than if you can't tell,
right?
So, if the message is so cleverly
corrupted that even your message
authentication technique, whatever it
may be, cannot tell that the message has
been corrupted, fails to detect that
corruption, then you're in trouble then.
But
if you can tell that the message has
been corrupted,
then
you can downgrade that Byzantine fault
of a message being corrupted to merely
an omission fault by dropping the
message on the floor and pretending that
you never got it.
So, really,
our picture here could distinguish
between the kinds of corrupted messages
that we can detect and those that we
can't necessarily detect. So, I could do
an extra sort of category here.
In uh in between omission faults and
Byzantine faults. And I'm going to call
this
authentication
detectable
Byzantine faults.
And what that means
is that
if you
have gotten a message, but you can
detect that it's been corrupted,
you can just drop or ignore the message.
So, basically, if you have good enough
message authentication techniques, you
can downgrade these certain kinds of
authentication detectable Byzantine
faults to merely omission faults.
Now, omission faults are still not
great,
but they're better than
having corrupted messages. So, the
specific details of what kind of
authentication technique you might use
are outside the scope of what we're
talking about in this class. If you
wanted to know more about that, then I
would suggest taking a security class.
Um but it's important to point out that,
you know, not every Byzantine fault has
to be the end of the world.
And so, the and and the bigger uh
point here is that these particular
classifications of faults that I've
written down here are not necessarily
the only way to do it. So, you could do
finer-grained classifications for a
given uh
application or in a given setting.
Uh so, the question in chat is, "So, in
general, narrowing it down is good?"
Well, the issue is that
tolerating Byzantine faults, like this
bigger circle, means anything could
happen, right? So,
if you have to tolerate Byzantine
faults, then you have to tolerate a
whole lot of bad behavior.
Uh
however, if you can say, "Well,
I can tolerate authentication detectable
Byzantine faults." It's nice to be able
to say exactly what it is that you can
tolerate. So, it's nice to be able to
define a classification of faults that
you can or cannot tolerate.
And um
it helps us reason about uh
what exactly it is that we that we can
or cannot cannot do. I find that um
it's it's fairly common for people to
use this term Byzantine fault when they
when they mean
uh something bad happened that we
weren't expecting.
Um but in practice it might merely turn
out to be a crash fault, or turn
omission fault that they weren't
expecting. So, the term Byzantine gets
thrown around a lot by people who want
to sound cool.
Uh but um
it's
what the fault that they're talking
about isn't necessarily a Byzantine
fault.
Uh so, I'm introducing all this
terminology so that you won't be like
them, so that you will use these terms
in the way that they're intended.
All right. And we talked about fault
models as well. So, just like we have
this nesting of faults, fault
classifications,
uh we have a nesting of fault models.
So, if you're operating in the crash
model, you can tolerate crash faults.
Then crash faults are the kinds of
faults that can occur in the fault
model.
There's another question in chat. So,
authentication-detectable Byzantine
fault just means no corrupted messages.
No, authentication-detectable
Byzantine faults is a class of faults
that may occur.
This is a class This is an This is a um
This figure is a classification of
different kinds of faults that may
occur.
And then, you can design your system in
a way that you can deal you can you need
to choose what kinds of faults you are
going to be able to tolerate.
And so, you would choose a fault model
that corresponds to the the kinds of
faults that you feel it's important to
be able to tolerate.
Depending on the resources that you have
and the the complexity budget of your
software.
And so, I mentioned before we're going
to be spending most of our time talking
about the omission fault model. And so,
omission faults are going to be what we
focus our attention on.
And um
I want to cover something else though. I
mentioned forms of fault tolerance. So,
fault models might be like this.
But that by itself can't possibly be the
whole story, right?
Because
let's say that I'm trying to implement
some software
and
I want it to tolerate a given class of
faults.
But what does it really mean to tolerate
a class of faults?
If you can tolerate a class of faults,
does that mean that if one of those
faults happens,
then you behave exactly like you would
have
if that fault hadn't happened?
Like let's say there's a crash fault.
Does it mean that your system has to
keep operating exactly the way that it
would have had that particular machine
not crashed?
So, this is an important question to
ask. It's not just as simple as, "Oh,
our system tolerates crash faults, for
example." Or, "Our system tolerates
omission faults."
The question is, what does your system
do in the presence of those faults? And
how much does it behavior change Does
its behavior change in the presence of
those faults?
So, we've talked a little bit about
safety and liveness properties and um
and what they are. So, we talked about
how a safety property says that a bad
thing
uh doesn't happen.
And a liveness property says that a good
thing does eventually happen.
So,
if a program is going to be correct, if
it's going to behave correctly,
it should satisfy both its safety and
its liveness properties, right? So, we
can say a correct program
A correct program satisfies both its
safety and its liveness properties.
Now, what happens in the presence of
faults? Well,
it would be really, really great
if let's say it's a crash fault, for
example.
It'd be really great if we could say
that our program continues to satisfy
both its safety and its liveness
properties in the presence of crash
faults.
But
that's sometimes too much to ask.
So,
maybe you have a program that
doesn't continue to satisfy its liveness
properties, let's say,
in the presence of a fault, but it does
continue to satisfy its safety
properties.
On the other hand, you could have a
program that only continues to satisfy
its liveness properties, but doesn't
continue to satisfy its safety
properties.
Um so, the question here is really, how
wrong does a program go in the presence
of a given class of faults?
So, we can introduce a little bit of
terminology for this as well.
And as so often, we can do a little
two-by-two grid
that will help us understand
the options.
So, let's say that we have a program
that in the presence of a given class of
faults, it could be crash faults or
whatever, remains both safe and live.
So, if it continues to satisfy both its
safety and liveness properties,
so we can call that kind of fault
tolerance masking.
Fault tolerance.
And that's
the holy grail, right? That's really
what you want.
But unfortunately, that's not always
possible.
So, what if you have a system that stays
safe that is continues to satisfy its
safety properties in the presence of a
given class of faults, but
doesn't stay live.
So, an example of this might be, you
know, we talked about FIFO delivery,
right?
So, safety in the case of FIFO delivery
means you never get messages that are
out of order, right? Out of out of the
FIFO order.
Uh but liveness means uh the the
liveness of an implementation of FIFO
delivery might be that messages
eventually get delivered, right?
So,
if in the presence of a fault, you keep
your liveness properties, but you don't
keep or sorry, if you keep your if you
keep your your your safety properties,
but you don't keep your liveness
properties, that's called fail-safe
behavior.
Or fail-safe
fault tolerance.
And that's
what's commonly discussed and commonly
studied. So, there's been a lot of focus
in distributed systems on making sure
that safety properties
get preserved in the presence of faults.
If you can't stay live,
so be it. It's not the end of the world.
But the the the the emphasis is on
ensuring that safety properties are
preserved.
On the other hand,
maybe sometimes
you're willing to give up safety
properties in favor of liveness.
So, this would be called non-masking
fault tolerance.
And then finally, this last category, if
if you're neither live nor safe in the
presence of faults, then that's just
sad.
So, the reason I'm talking about this is
because there's really more to this
picture than just these uh the just
fault classifications. And there's more
to say about a given program than just,
"Oh, it tolerates crash faults." Or, "It
tolerates omission faults."
There's also the question of
what does it mean to say that it
tolerates a class of faults, right? What
behavior will it have in the presence of
those faults? So, you know, we'd love it
if in the presence of faults that
everything would continue to satisfy
both its safety and liveness properties,
and then we'd have masking fault
tolerance, which would be really, really
nice. Um
but most of the time, so this is like
the happy face case over here, but most
of the time we can't have that. So, most
of the time
the compromise that we might choose
would be to continue to preserve the
safety properties. Continue to ensure
that those messages keep getting uh
that those messages don't get delivered
in the wrong order, right? Even if it
means you have to stop delivering
messages for a while, don't deliver them
in the wrong order. That would be
fail-safe fault tolerance.
And that's so that's often what we end
up going with.
And some other systems might choose a
different compromise, right? They might
say, "Keep delivering messages. It's
okay if they have to go out of order for
a while, but keep on delivering them."
Which Which should you choose? Well, I
can't answer that question for you. It's
going to be be depend on the needs of
your application and the situation that
they're in.
So, there's some great discussion in
chat right now.
Um
Yeah, so I think Patrick has some really
good insight into this um having having
worked in industry for a while.
Uh so, uh he's a good person to talk to
about this stuff uh
sometime in office hours.
What we're going to jump into next is
implementing reliable delivery. So, if
you recall from last time we began to
talk about this notion of reliable
delivery.
And we're going to define it again. We
already defined it last time, but we're
going to define it one more time.
So, recall that this is a liveness
property.
So, here's what we said before.
Let P1 be a process
that sends a message
M
to process P2.
If neither P1 nor P2 crashes
And then here's this
parenthetical we added last time.
And not all messages are lost
P2
eventually delivers M.
So, we had a little bit of a discussion
last time about
do we need this part here where we say
not all messages are lost?
So, now that we've discussed fault
models and fault classification
uh we can talk about this in a little
bit more detail. So
do we need this part?
We do if we're working under the
omission model.
So, I mentioned that the omission model
was going to be where we would be
spending most of our time in this class.
So if omission faults can happen
then we have to design for that, and so
we have to define reliable delivery in a
way that accounts for that. In the
omission model, messages can get lost.
So, we have to throw in this extra
clause here.
The omission model is more realistic
than just assuming the crash model. So,
we'd better stick with the omission
model. So, we
definitely need this and not all
messages are lost bit. reliable
delivery?
If Alice has to get a message to Bob how
can she do so reliably?
Any suggestions?
So, here's a good suggestion. Yeah,
acknowledge messages and keep sending
until you get one. Yeah. So, Alice can
just keep sending over and over
until she gets an ack. So, if Alice
wants to send a message
here's what she can do.
When she wants to send a message
she can put it in sort of buffer, like a
send buffer on her side.
So, she'll have a um she'll be she can
implement timeouts on her side. She's
got a monotonic clock, so she can
implement timeouts. And so, her
algorithm would go like this.
Put message in send buffer.
Whenever the timeout expires
send what's in the send buffer.
So, don't delete it from the buffer yet.
Just send whatever whatever is there.
And then
when an ack is received for a sent
message, then you can delete it from the
send buffer.
So, Alice is just going to keep sending
and maybe a bunch of her messages get
lost, right?
And every time the timeout expires,
she's going to send again. Sooner or
later
if a message gets through to Bob
and he acks it
then Alice can delete her message from
the send buffer, and she knows that that
message has been received.
You see any issues with this
implementation?
Okay, yeah, so one question is, "How do
you know how long the timeout should
be?" Yeah, so that's kind of the open
question that we talked about on day one
of class, also.
Yeah, Alice doesn't know how long the
timeout should be, particularly because
we're talking about the asynchronous
network model always in this class.
We're talking about the asynchronous
network model where there could be some
unbounded latency between Alice and Bob.
So we don't know, right? And Alice could
try to do clever things. You know, she
could uh
she could try to
uh
figure out how long it's taken in the
past for for Bob to acknowledge her
messages and then adjust her uh her
timeout accordingly.
Yeah, so certainly picking an
appropriate timeout length is tough. If
you pick something that's too small,
then
you're going to expire the timeout much
more often than necessary. If you pick
something that's too long, then
uh then you might not be sending
messages uh
as as often as you could.
Any other problems here?
Any other issues with this
implementation?
Well, what about this?
What if Bob's ack got dropped?
Well, then Alice will keep sending,
right?
So, we know that
eventually some
uh some ack will get through from Bob
because uh
we're Well
if the specification of the protocol
we're trying to implement says not all
messages are lost, right?
So
eventually some ack will get through
here.
Um but what would that mean? If Bob's
ack was dropped, it would mean that Bob
would get
this message from Alice twice, right?
Cuz eventually her message would get
through again.
So this is the same message every time.
So if this message got dropped, Alice
would think she had to send it again.
So here is Bob is getting M twice.
Is that a problem?
For Bob to get a message twice?
Yeah, it depends, right? I think it
depends on the message.
So not too long ago, last time when we
were talking about the two generals
problem, and we were talking about
workarounds for the two generals
problem,
one of the workarounds that we came up
with relied on sending the message again
and again
until we got an ack,
right?
So we had something like where Alice
would send attack at dawn
over and over.
And let's say both of these get through.
Let's say Bob got this one and
acknowledged it, and then his ack didn't
land until here.
So this uh approach relies on sending
the same message over and over and again
until you get an ack.
And you have to assume that it's going
to be okay if more than one gets
through.
So is this a problem? Well,
hm
maybe not, right?
Like if the if the problem here is to
decide when to attack,
if Bob hears attack at dawn twice,
is that so bad?
Right? They both say attack at dawn.
It's not as though this one changes what
Bob is supposed to do.
It just means he's
getting told the same thing again.
So if Bob actually got this first
message from Alice and he acted, then
and but then it took a while for his ack
to arrive,
you know, he might get an extra copy of
the attack at dawn message.
But that message wouldn't actually
change his mind, right? Like he's not
going to say, "Oh, she said attack at
dawn twice. That means I shouldn't
really attack at dawn." No, no, no. No.
It's not going to mean anything
different for Bob in this situation if
he gets a duplicate of the attack at
dawn message.
In general, some messages will have this
property and others won't.
So
let's say that I'm assigning a value to
a key in a key-value store. So
I'm a client.
And here's the key-value store.
So I send the message
set X to 3.
And let's say that that message gets
duplicated.
If that message gets duplicated, do you
think that it's a problem?
Yeah, I I would say no, right? If I get
the message on the KVS side,
and I see that I'm supposed to set X to
3,
and then a minute later I also hear that
I'm supposed to set X to 3, I mean,
is that going to be the same result as
if I just got the message once? Yeah.
So that's not so bad. Now, you could
say, "Well, this is a problem if, you
know, maybe there's another client over
here, right?"
Who's saying
set X to 4, right?
So if I say this,
in that case this second message did
have an effect.
Then we have a problem, right? But you
know what?
This first message here
from our first client, call this client
one and call this one client two. The
first message from client one also could
have taken longer. The first message
from client one also could have landed
here.
So
even if there was only one message from
client one and only one message from
client two, you could still get into
this problem where client one overwrites
client two's message. So
the multiple clients issue is not
actually an issue with the message
getting sent twice.
It's an issue with the two clients
trying to write to the same key in in
the key-value store.
And the the key-value store has to apply
those updates in some order, right? It's
got to It's got to either apply client
one's update and then client two's
update, or it has to apply client two's
update and then client one's update. So
somebody's going to be sad.
We'll talk more later in the course
about how to deal with this kind of
thing. But anyway,
my my point here is that
this issue where client one and client
two are both kind of fighting over what
X should be is not actually an issue um
with the message getting sent twice,
because the same issue could occur even
if the client uh the first client only
sent a message once. There's still some
uncertainty about the order in which
these two messages will land here on the
KVS.
So I would argue that
this actually isn't the concern that
we're dealing with right now.
So just in terms of messages from this
one client,
is it a problem that we're sending
multiple messages that set X to 3? And I
would say no.
I would say that
if I'm getting these messages on the KVS
side and I'm told that I'm supposed to
set X to 3, and then later I'm also told
that I'm set supposed to set X to 3,
it's the same as if I had just gotten
the messages once.
On the other hand,
what if the message was this?
What if the message is increment X? What
if that one gets in what get What if
that one gets uh duplicated?
Yeah, it's no good, right? Cuz
incrementing X twice is different from
incrementing X once.
So the word for
a message that it's okay to receive more
than once
is item potent.
And this is a word that I think some of
you knew cuz you were already using it.
So you might be familiar with this term
from uh from math where we talk about
the concept of item potent functions.
So
what is an item potent function? Well,
that's when
uh so we say F is item potent
if
if you have f of x,
that's the same as f of f of x,
and then also of course that means it's
the same as f of f of f of x and so on.
So that that what that's what makes a
function item potent if we're talking
about functions. In the context of this
course for distributed systems,
we say that a message is item potent if
if it's okay to receive it more than
once because the effect of applying it
more than once
is going to be the same as the effect of
applying it only once.
So set X to 3 is considered an item
potent message.
Incrementing a variable is not an item
And item potence is really important in
distributed systems because generally
speaking,
a good way to make sure something gets
done is to try to do it a bunch of times
until at least one attempt will succeed.
So this isn't always going to be
possible. So, sometimes we need
operations that aren't idempotent.
But, if we can, generally speaking,
we're going to have an easier time of it
when we're working with item potent
operations.
So, what does this have to do with
reliable delivery? Well, it turns out
that in order to implement reliable
delivery,
we need to
deliver a message more than once.
Sometimes.
So, reliable delivery is sometimes
called at least once delivery.
So, the way to make sure a message is
reliable deliver reliably delivered,
just deliver it a bunch of times until
it gets through, until you get an
acknowledgement.
And it had better be the case that you
figure out to deal with possible
duplicates on the receiving side.
So, that's why we call it at least once
delivery because
you could ensure that it gets through
reliably,
but you
it to to go along with that, you have to
allow for the possibility that it might
get delivered more than once.
What about at most once delivery? How
would you How do you get that? What if
you wanted to implement at most once
delivery?
Yeah, it's really easy. You know, just
send a message.
If it arrives, great. If not, great.
Yeah, so drop the messages after the
first one. Or better yet, just don't do
anything, right? You know?
Zero time delivery is the same as at
most once delivery.
So, at most at most once delivery is
very easy to implement.
What about exactly once delivery?
So, if we can have at least once, and we
can have at most once,
is exactly once delivery possible?
Is that a thing we can have?
Yeah, it's it's not sounding optimistic
in the chat. Probably not.
So, there are systems out there that
claim to provide exactly once delivery.
So,
what do you think they really mean? If
they're claiming to have exactly once
delivery, what do they actually mean?
What do you think?
Almost once.
I like that.
So, I I'll say this.
If you encounter
systems out in the world that claim to
provide exactly once delivery,
or if you encounter people who claim
that their system provides exactly once
delivery,
usually they mean one of two things.
The message is write idempotent anyway.
So, maybe the messages are getting
delivered more than once, but it doesn't
have an effect. Right? So, if the
messages are write idempotent,
that's like our
set x to three
example.
So, they're calling it exactly once,
and what they mean is that the message
is write idempotent anyway, so the
behavior ends up being the same as if
the message arrived exactly once, but
that wasn't in fact what was happening.
Or another possibility is
The other possibility is that they're
making an effort to deduplicate
messages. So, on the receiving end,
if they get more than one of a message,
they're trying to detect that
and and remove the duplicates. That's
right. That's correct. The question in
chat was they do So, they do something
that drops all the duplicate duplicates?
Yeah, so it means they try to do
something to to drop the duplicates and
only apply one.
This is what I think people mean when
they go around claiming exactly once
delivery.
It's not something that you can really
have. However, you can get reasonably
close in practice by trying to do these
things, but I would be skeptical of
anybody who claims that their system
gives you exactly once delivery, like an
exactly once message queue or something
like that.
All right.
I think now would be a good time to
pause and do our quiz question.
So, it's 4:06 right now. Let's return at
4:16.
And here's today's quiz question.
I'll see you in 10 minutes.
Right, 2-minute warning.
All right, it's 4:19, so let's start up
again.
Welcome back.
All right, so we've been spending a lot
of time talking about
fault models, reliable delivery, item
potency,
little bit on
exactly once delivery and how that's
kind of not real.
Uh to The next thing that I want to talk
about is um
reliable broadcast.
So, let's refresh our memory uh from
before
about what this word broadcast means.
Uh so we defined broadcast previously.
Can somebody remind me what it means?
Yeah, so it means somebody sends and
everybody receives it. That's right.
And that's in contrast to uh to unicast
or point-to-point messages, which have
one sender and one receiver.
Or multicast messages, which are where
where one sends and many, more than one,
receive. And so broadcast is a special
case of multicast, where one sends and
everybody receives.
So we we talked about broadcast
communication before in the context of
causal broadcast, right? So
just to refresh our memory,
if we were using a causal broadcast
protocol,
then a causal anomaly couldn't happen.
Like if you had something like this,
and you tried to send a message like
this,
the causal broadcast protocol would stop
you from delivering this one at this
point. Instead, it would get buffered.
Or queued, I guess, is the word that we
used for it before.
And it would get bumped until later.
So this message could get delivered
right away.
Um, and this message could get delivered
right away. But this message here would
have to get buffered and only get
delivered later.
So broadcast communication means this
sort of one-to-all communication.
And if I wanted to, I could draw the the
little self arrows in here so we could
see that these processes were also
sending and delivering to themselves,
but most of the time we don't bother.
All right.
So
the question now is how do you reliably
broadcast a message?
We talked about reliable delivery a
minute ago. So
we're going to assume that there's a
built-in primitive to begin you to be
begin with that lets you send a message
from one sender to one receiver. So
we're not going to be talking in this
class about how to implement sending a
message from you to one receiver.
That might be something that you would
study in networking or something like
that. But assuming that you have that
built-in primitive,
how would you go about implementing
broadcast?
So
if you have a unicast primitive,
just for sending a message to one
receiver,
um
how do you implement broadcast?
Forget even the reliable part for now.
Just how do you implement broadcast if
you have this unicast primitive?
What do you think?
Yeah, just a unicast to every process.
Yeah, you can implement broadcast by
just sending a series of unicast
messages. So
if I
Alice want to send a message to Bob and
Carol saying that Bob smells,
then I can send it to Bob and then
almost at the same time send it to
Carol.
So
if we were to zoom into this picture, we
draw just one dot here because we think
of this is just being one message, the
Bob smells message.
And likewise, we think of this one is
just being one message.
But
under the hood, this is actually two
messages. So if we were to zoom in to
what
Alice's process line looks like,
it's actually sending a message
and then a little bit later
it's sending another message. So
this is the zoomed-in view of what's
going on.
So under the hood, these are actually
separate unicast messages. But the way
that I want to think about them
is as having the same send event. So I
want to be able to think of them that
way. And in fact, we have been thinking
of them that way all along
when we draw these multiple arrows with
the same start point like this.
So we think of the sends as being a
single event, which it should be. That's
how it should be. But under the hood,
something like this is going on.
Okay.
How do we make this reliable? Okay, so
reliable broadcast. Let's define it.
If a correct process
delivers
M, M is a broadcast message,
then all
correct processes deliver M.
So here
we're assuming that M is a broadcast
message.
Before I get any further,
what do you think this correct process
thing means? What's a correct process?
Knows how to correctly unicast, okay.
Certainly that's one thing that I might
expect the correct process to do.
So the last the last couple of
of days we've been talking about um
reliable delivery, right? And we and we
talked about a couple of different
versions of reliable delivery. So once
we said,
no, reliable delivery means that if P1
sends a message to P2, then if neither
P1 nor P2 crashes, then P2 eventually
delivers the message.
And then the other version that we came
up with
said the same thing, but it also added
this extra caveat that also not all
messages are lost. So why? Why did we
define
reliable delivery in these two different
ways?
Well, it's because
it depends what the definition that we
want depends on the assumptions of the
different fault models.
If your fault model is the crash model,
like we said, then message loss isn't a
thing. So it's okay then to define this
reliable delivery property without
talking about message loss.
On the other hand, if you're in the
omission model, then message loss can
occur. So then you have to have this
extra caveat that says not all messages
are lost.
If you're in the Byzantine fault model,
you'd have to have another caveat. You'd
have to say, reliable delivery is if,
no, P1 sends a message to P2
and nobody exhibits any Byzantine
behavior,
as well as the other uh caveats that we
had about neither crashing or or neither
or not all messages being lost,
then
process two eventually delivers the
message. So you have to add all these
different caveats. So
it'd be nice if we could define these
kinds of properties in a way that's
independent of the particular fault
model
that we happen to be using at the
moment.
And we can. So
there's a way to define it that's
general enough to subsume these earlier
definitions. And that this that's this
correct process business.
So what does correct process mean? What
does it What does it mean for a process
to be correct?
It depends on your fault model.
So
if you're working in the crash model,
where the bad thing that can go wrong is
that a process can crash, a correct
process is one that
hasn't crashed.
So what I've done here is I've I've
taken the meaning of what it means to be
correct in different fault models. And
instead of sticking all of those
different caveats into the definition
here,
we're abstracting over it by just saying
correct process.
And so whenever you see a definition
like this that says correct process,
your next question should be, what is
the fault model? Because that's going to
tell you what it means to talk about
what a what a correct process is.
That's kind of like
in security,
uh if somebody asks,
is this safe?" Right?
If they If they ask if a particular
piece of software is safe, the question
to ask is, "What is the threat model?"
Right? What kind of threats is it
supposed to be safe against? Is this
software secure?
There's no way to answer that without
knowing what the threat model is.
This is not a security course, but
there's something kind of analogous
going on here. So, with with um
when we say, "Is a process correct?" The
The right response to that question is,
"What is your fault model?"
Okay.
So, back to talking about reliable
broadcast. So, this time we're just
putting in this correct process
terminology from the start.
And let's say just for now
that we're just working within the crash
model.
So, message loss doesn't happen, but we
do have to confront the possibility of
processes crashing.
So, I'll say for now,
crash model.
That means that when we talk about a
process being correct, we mean
a process that doesn't crash.
Okay.
So, suppose we have Alice, Bob, and
Carol.
Let's say
that Alice sends a message to Bob and
Carol like this.
Let's say that Bob successfully delivers
the message.
However, let's say that Carol crashes
before she can deliver the message.
Maybe she even received it,
but then crashed
right here.
Would that be a violation
of reliable broadcast?
No, that's right.
Carol crashed, so she's not a correct
process. So, it's okay that she didn't
deliver the message.
What about this?
So, I'm going to go back to drawing
our three processes, and I'll continue
to zoom in here on this uh This is You
can think of this as being a single
broadcast, and under the hood it's these
two unicast messages.
So, let's say Alice sends her message to
Bob.
It gets delivered.
But then let's say Alice crashed before
sending to Carol.
And Carol went along not crashing.
Do you think this would violate the
reliable broadcast property?
This is kind of a interesting one.
Yeah, so keep in mind we said, "Reliable
broadcast means if a correct process
delivers M, then all correct processes
deliver M." Well, Carol's over here.
She didn't crash.
So, she's a correct process.
She didn't deliver the message.
So,
it's kind of looking like this is not
reliable broadcast. The The point of
confusion here is that you could argue
that Alice didn't actually manage to
finish broadcasting the message. So, you
could argue that it's not
a broadcast message to begin with.
Um but I mean, I think you can do a
little better than that, right? Because
I I I think you could say that this is
in fact in violation of the spec
because
you can imagine that there's a little
tag on every message that says,
"I'm a broadcast message."
Right? Because when this message went
out, it didn't know that Alice was going
to crash later.
So,
it's expecting
that the other broadcasts are or the
rather the rest of the unicast messages
are going to happen, making it a
broadcast. So,
Bob's gotten this message with its tag
that says, "I'm a broadcast."
Bob is sitting here thinking, "Oh, I've
gotten a broadcast.
Carol must have gotten it, too, or she
must be about to."
So, you could say that yeah, this is in
violation of the specification.
So, even if the sender crashed before
sending it to everyone, you can tell
that this message is in fact supposed to
be broadcast, and so this You can say
that something went wrong here. So,
knowing that a process can crash in the
middle of trying to broadcast a message,
can anyone think of a way that we could
still get reliable broadcast?
So, knowing this can happen,
can we still get reliable broadcast?
Take a second to think about it.
All right.
Some good suggestions already. So,
somebody said, "Well, you could send to
Carol after this." But the trouble is
Alice has crashed here. So,
she's crashed. She's not coming back.
There's another great suggestion in
chat, which is that Bob could send to
Carol. Yeah.
I think you're on the right track with
that.
So, I'm going to propose the following.
When you receive a message that's
supposed to be a broadcast message,
you don't deliver it yet. Instead, you
broadcast it to everyone else.
And only once you've done that, do you
actually deliver it?
So, let's see how that would work.
So, let's say Alice sends to Bob,
and then she crashes. So, she's done.
Bob gets the message.
Uh but he doesn't deliver it yet.
Instead,
he's going to forward a copy of it onto
everyone else.
So, if you wanted, you know, you could
add an optimization that says that, you
know, he doesn't send it back to the
sender.
Um
but
he could also send it back to the
sender. Whatever.
So, he'll forward it to everybody else,
and only after doing that will he
deliver it himself.
And Carol, when she gets the message,
she knows that she got a message from
Bob, right?
But she doesn't know if everybody else
has it yet. So, Carol, when she gets the
message, she's also going to forward a
copy
to Alice and Bob.
And then she delivers it. Now, Alice
crashed, right? So, she's These messages
don't actually get to her, right?
Because she crashed.
But this is a way
that Carol can still get the message
even though the original sender crashed.
So, let's try to think of some
possibilities here of things that could
go wrong. So,
what would happen if Bob crashed
right here
before sending to Carol, for example?
Well, if Bob crashed right here
before sending to Carol, then Carol
would never get the message, right? And
so, none of this stuff would happen.
But then, Bob would never deliver the
message himself
because Bob doesn't deliver the message
until he's after done in until after
he's sent the message to Carol.
So, then Bob would never deliver the
message himself. So, then nobody would
be delivering the message, right? And
remember, reliable broadcast says, "If a
correct process delivers the message,
then then everybody does.
But if Bob crashed right here, then
nobody would deliver the message. So,
the precondition wouldn't be met, so
we'd be okay.
So, that would actually be fine.
Okay?
What if Bob sent to Carol and then
crashed?
Like right here.
Well, then
Carol would get the message, but now
everybody's crashed except Carol.
So, Carol is the only correct process.
So, now whether or not she delivers the
message now
we'll still be satisfying the reliable
broadcast property.
Because there's only one correct process
left. So, she can basically do what she
wants at this point.
And it won't be in violation of the
reliable broadcast property.
So, it turns out that this algorithm
that I've sketched out works in general.
And so, the way that I wrote it here, um
we had processes sending back to
wherever they received a message from.
And that's actually unnecessary. So, we
can cut out that extra optimization.
Or rather, we can make an optimization
that that that cuts out those messages.
Is this protocol going to result in
people receiving duplicate messages
sometimes?
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, I mean, suppose no one crashes,
right? Then we have this.
Then we have Alice sending
to Bob and Carol.
We have Bob getting the message here
and sending it to everybody except the
sender. So, you know, he sends it to
Carol.
And we have Carol getting the message
and sending it to everybody except the
sender. So, she sends it
uh
to Alice.
Actually, I did that wrong.
Um
So, in this case here, Alice uh sends
the message to Carol. Both of these
messages get through.
Uh Carol is going to send this one to
Bob as well.
Yeah, and I guess this one is still
here.
So, what happens? Well,
it looks like Bob got the mess- or it
looks like Carol got the message more
than once.
Actually, I'm confused by my own picture
here. Let me try it again.
Sorry.
Usually, I try to practice a little
more. All right. So,
this is the setting where nobody
crashed.
So, Alice is going to broadcast to
everybody. Bob gets the message. He
says, "Okay, I better send to everybody
except the sender.
So, I'll send it here."
Carol gets this message and says, "Okay,
I better send it to everybody except the
sender.
I'll send it here."
And Carol gets this message and says,
"Okay, I better send it to everybody
except the sender. I'll send it here."
Okay.
So, Bob and Carol would each get the
message twice.
So, here's Carol getting the message
twice.
Um
Bob got the message here and he he got
it again here.
Alice got her own message.
So,
something that they can do
is keep track of what messages
they've delivered, right?
So, after Bob sends here,
he's going to deliver the message to
himself. And so, he knows he doesn't
need to deliver it again at this point.
Likewise,
Alice delivered to herself here.
So, she's delivered the message. So, so
she knows she doesn't have to deliver it
back to herself if she gets it again.
And similarly here,
after Carol sends the message to Alice,
then she can deliver it here. So, she
knows she doesn't have to deliver it
again.
So, something they can do is keep track
of what messages they've delivered. And
then if they get one that they've
already delivered, if they receive one
they've already delivered, they don't
have to deliver it again.
And furthermore, with forwarding, if
they've already delivered a message,
they don't have to forward it again.
Okay, so there's a question.
Uh what if Bob receives Carol's
broadcast before he delivers to himself?
So, after it the the protocol says that
after you send
on to everybody except the one that you
got it from, you deliver to yourself
right then. So, that can be thought of
as sort of an atomic thing that you do.
You send to everybody else, and then
right after you've done that, you
deliver to yourself. So, you're
wondering if it's possible that a
message could sneak in between that
time. Well, that seems unlikely because
the message would have to get all the
way to Carol, right? And then all the
way back to you before you delivered it.
Um
So, I don't think that's too much of a
concern, actually.
Uh somebody asked me to label the
processes. Well, sure.
So, the big idea that I want to leave
you with here,
which we saw examples of both a minute
ago when we were talking about reliable
delivery and we said that we could
accomplish reliable delivery by just
sending copies of messages until you got
an ack, right?
And now this time with reliable
broadcast,
there's kind of a big thing that's going
on in both.
Uh which is that
fault tolerance
often involves
making lots of copies.
So, this is kind of a
key idea
of this course.
Fault tolerance often involves making
copies.
So, in the case of reliable delivery,
we were able to tolerate message loss by
sending multiple copies and until at
least one got through.
In the case of reliable broadcast,
we were able to tolerate processes
crashing by making copies of received
messages and forwarding them.
Okay, somebody just asked a good
question in chat. This is all just
talking about the crash model, right?
The only bad thing that I was talking
about here was crashing.
Could you make this reliable broadcast
protocol work in the omission model?
What would you have to do?
That's right. Yeah, I mean, you have to
be tolerant of lost messages.
So, how do you do that? Well,
you kind of already know the answer
because we already talked about reliable
delivery. So, the answer is
do what you're doing here, but use the
reliable delivery mechanism that we
talked about before
of sending messages multiple times until
you get an ack, and only then, you know,
consider them to have been sent.
And layer
this reliable broadcast on top of that
underlying reliable delivery mechanism.
So, if you did that, you could make this
reliable broadcast protocol work in the
omission model, too.
So, in this case, process crashing, like
when we talk about a process crashing,
we're mostly worried about processes
crashing in the middle of trying to do a
broadcast, right?
So,
you can think of that as being a kind of
message loss as well, even though we're
still just in the crash model. But that
makes sense, right? Because we know that
crash faults can be thought of as a
special case of omission faults. Crash
faults are the special case of omission
faults where all the messages to and
from a particular process are lost.
So, what's going on here
is that we're mitigating message loss by
making copies, making copies of
messages.
Questions about that?
Or questions about anything that we've
discussed so far?
Okay.
So, in the 5 minutes that we have left,
I want to ask you a question that kind
of
branches off of this claim. I say fault
tolerance often involves making copies
here.
So, we've just been talking about
mitigating message loss.
Oh, somebody just asked, "Why does it
often involve making copies?" Well,
well, what did we have to do to ensure
reliable message delivery? We had to
make copies of messages, right? We had
to keep on sending copies of messages
until some message got through.
Likewise here,
you had to make a Alice or Bob had to
make a copy of this message uh from
Alice
and forwarded it on to Carol. So, that's
how we accomplished reliable broadcast
in this picture.
But,
what else un- under what other
circumstances does this principle apply?
So, we've been talking about mitigating
message loss.
But, what else in distributed systems?
What else other than messages do you
have to be concerned about losing?
No suggestions, huh?
What if you're a
What if you're a process and you know
that X is 3 and Y is 4?
And then you crash.
Well, you've lost that information,
right?
How do you mitigate that loss of data?
What can you do about that?
You should reuse redundancy. What does
that mean?
Store things multiple places. Exactly.
You make copies.
If you're a process and you have some
state and you crash,
but if there's another copy, then the
data isn't lost forever.
So, making copies can help us mitigate
loss of messages. It can also help us
mitigate loss of data or state, in other
words. Processes keep state.
Or equivalent- equivalently, processes
keep data.
So,
we can mitigate data loss by making
copies of it. Or in other words,
replication.
This is going to be our next big topic.
So,
if you have some state
and you crash,
having another copy will ensure that
that that state isn't lost forever.
That's the most important reason to do
replication.
There are other reasons to do it, too.
Like if you have more than one process,
then maybe you can serve more requests,
right?
And you can divide up the work, so not
every not only one process has to do all
the work. You can also have one process
close to some of the users and have the
other process close to some of the other
users, so that you can serve your users
more effectively.
But, the most important reason to do it
is to guard against data loss.
So,
that's what replication is about.
And we're going to get into talking
about replication next time and we're
going to start talking about techniques
for replication.
Right? I will see you next Tuesday.
I look forward to it.